we took Tommy to look at the mudflats in
Cook Inlet Anchorage sits on a series of
bluffs that overlook Cook Inlet and it
has the second highest tides in the
world
it's a 37-foot tide at its most extreme
so when the tide goes out Cook Inlet
miles of these mud flats are exposed and
this marshy tidal area is a fabulous
duck hunting location I used to walk
down from my house and duck hunt down
here as a teenager
next we stopped at potter's marsh which
is the park south of Anchorage beautiful
place where you see wildlife and moves
birds and even salmon swimming upstream
it's a beautiful location it was nearby
so I took Tommy to to check out the Sam
and get to see some salmon up close and
personal
these are two pink salmon and one of
them's rotting to death from old age and
this right here is a silver salmon when
they get old they turn all pink I told
Tommy we'd go fishing so he took off
running for the car